[Musica]
[Applauso]
voglio confidarvi un segreto
una cosa su di me che non dico spesso ad
alta voce io non sono una persona
tollerante
ecco capisco che è un'affermazione del
genere possa creare imbarazzo mettere a
disagio ma lasciate che vi spieghi
perché sono fermamente convinto che
costruire il futuro della nostra società
attorno all'idea le della tolleranza
rappresenti un errore anzi una svista
imperdonabile negli ultimi 20 anni siamo
stati testimoni di alcuni fenomeni
culturali massivi da migrazioni su larga
scala all'insorgere di movimenti
fondamentalisti violenti fino allo
svilupparsi di un odio diffuso nei
confronti delle minoranze le democrazie
occidentali per gestire queste
agitazioni sociali hanno deciso di
schierare uno degli strumenti cardine
della propria narrazione politica la
retorica della tolleranza
ma che cos'è
questa cosa chiamata tolleranza e
soprattutto perché come se tutti ci
sentissimo spontaneamente in dovere di
difendere questa tolleranza nelle
società occidentali
la tolleranza rappresenta un valore la
cui diffusione e tutela vengono
incentivate ciecamente e mai messa in
dubbio un valore che appare radicato
nella nostra stessa idea di cultura
un'idea che si compone di ideali come il
rispetto la civiltà e appunto da
tolleranza ideali in cui ci riconosciamo
riconosciamo le nostre origini e di cui
andiamo fieri negli stati uniti per
esempio il concetto di tolleranza per il
vicino viene spesso considerato un
elemento chiave per garantire una
pacifica convivenza dei differenti
gruppi etnici all'interno della stessa
comunità
specie in quelle aree urbane e suburbane
più esposte al crimine bene ma cosa
succederebbe se io vi dicessi che in
realtà la tolleranza un anima oscura e
che tutti noi siamo partecipi autori e
anche vittime di un grande inganno
un inganno che rischia di mettere a
repentaglio il nostro ed altrui futuro
per scorgere il vero volto della nozione
di tolleranza
dobbiamo però fare un passo indietro e
tornare fino al xvi secolo quando l'idea
stessa di tolleranza è venuta alla luce
il concetto di tolleranza
tolleranza religiosa emerge dagli
sviluppi successivi a quello che fu
probabilmente uno dei periti più cruenti
e tinti di sangue della storia recente
dell'umanità l'era della riforma
protestante e della relativa
controriforma durante il 1600
l'equilibrio dell'europa cristiana era
sotto attacco
le predicazioni eversive di alcuni
notabili riformatori martin lutero
giovanni calvino stavano mettendo il
dubbio il monopolio che roma esercitava
sulla parola di dio mentre focolai di
antisemitismo divampavano per tutta
l'europa continentale
la risposta del soglio pontificio alle
crescenti tensioni e reti che non si
fece attendere guerra persecuzioni e il
fuoco dei roghi centinaia di migliaia di
persone furono inquisite perseguitate
addirittura giustiziate nel nome
dell'unità della chiesa il sedicesimo e
diciassettesimo secolo furono se il
salto tra i beve di più intolleranti
della storia della cristianità a partire
dal xvii secolo tuttavia qualcosa cambiò
la gente cominciò a pensare che fosse
ingiustificabile utilizzare strumenti
come la violenza la coercizione la
repressione nel nome della religione
la crudeltà della controriforma aprì una
ferita profonda nel tessuto sociale
dell'europa
alla fine dei combattimenti
entrambe le parti erano finite esauste
fu in questo momento che l'idea della
tolleranza religiosa emerse come
il metodo più vantaggioso per arginare
il problema delle minoranze evitando di
ricorrere al conflitto armato ben presso
la marginalizzazione sociale sostituii
fioretti e la discriminazione culturale
prese il posto dei moschetti
torniamo al presente ciò che ti
fondamentale ci insegna la crudeltà
della controriforma è che nella storia
il metodo più vantaggioso che i gruppi
dominanti hanno trovato per gestire il
problema delle minoranze siano queste
religiose politiche sociali non è stato
quello di combatterle
ma di tollerarle pensateci combattere
significherebbe impegnarsi in una guerra
che non si è sicuri di vincere
stanziando dalle risorse che non si è
sicuri possedere e accettando divaricare
dei limiti che non si è davvero sicuri
di voler oltrepassare l'espediente della
tolleranza offre una soluzione a buon
mercato si isolano i membri del gruppo
sociale minoritario all'interno di una
zona sicura protetta tutelata senza
ricorrere al conflitto armato e senza
mettere in discussione la propria
posizione dominante
questo meccanismo
offre la possibilità ai membri del
gruppo dominante di costituire una sorta
di riserva per gli individui tollerati
ora la metafora della riserva o del
recinto è particolarmente calzante
pensate al caso delle comunità per gli
indiani nativi in nord america gli
individui membri del gruppo dominante
erigono una sorta di recinto uno
steccato metaforico all'interno del
quale accordano agli altri
il permesso di esistere e questi
cosiddetti altri verranno sempre
considerati inferiori o potenzialmente
dannosi per la comunità ecco svelato
l'inganno il recinto che il gruppo
dominante erige attorno al gruppo
sociale minoritario non è costruito per
proteggere per tutelare dal crimine
dalla violenza del conflitto o almeno
quella non è la sua funzione principale
esso è primariamente fattore di
isolamento discriminazione segregazione
gli individui che vengono tollerati
sono considerati in una parola barbari
hoc stranieri facciamo un esempio
alcuni sostengono che sia necessario
mantenere un atteggiamento tollerante
nei confronti degli omosessuali
sottintendendo implicitamente che la
politica della tolleranza rappresenti
una alternativa valida o addirittura più
funzionale rispetto al pieno
riconoscimento legale delle loro unioni
per esempio
ecco questa tesi appare intuitivamente
molto diversa da sostenere che la
tolleranza alla stregua di un muro di
cinta protegga dal crimine dal caos
dalla violenza qui la tolleranza non è
concepita come un'alternativa
all'isolamento sociale o addirittura
alla persecuzione
no qui la tolleranza è concepita
precisamente come un'alternativa
all'uguaglianza uno schema che si è
messo in pratica non fa altro che ma
anche l'inferiorità dello status sociale
degli omosessuali ferrea e indiscutibile
se nel 1600 il concetto di tolleranza
era stato costruito per evitare il
conflitto
ora non dobbiamo pensare che l'unica
alternativa possibile al conflitto sia
la tolleranza questa erige muta
all'interno di una comunità mura che
impedisce impediscono il dialogo il
confronto e la collaborazione tra le
diverse nicchie culturali che abitano
una stessa società non vedere
che queste mura sono erette non per
proteggere ma per isolare è un tranello
in cui diamo troppo spesso un tranello
che ci coinvolge tutti e di cui tutti
siamo vittime come ci sentiremmo ad
essere isolati in un recinto supportati
per chi siamo
o per ciò in cui crediamo nel 1963
martin luther king aveva un sogno che i
suoi figli vivessero in un'azione in cui
non fossero giudicati per il colore
della loro pelle ma per ciò che la loro
persona conteneva la politica della
tolleranza ci sta portando verso un
mondo in cui per evitare il dialogo
costruiamo recinti steccati che ci
dividono dalle persone che giudichiamo
diverse da noi a cui non riserviamo
dignità e rispetto ma soltanto una
silenziosa e subdola disapprovazione la
politica della tolleranza ci sta
traghettando verso un futuro in cui le
differenze culturali sono considerate un
problema un problema per cui è
necessaria una soluzione
questo è un futuro non solo di cui il
dottor king non sarebbe felice ma che
noi non ci meritiamo
io studio filosofia
se c'è una cosa che ho imparato dalle
mie letture dalle persone che ho
conosciute dall'esperienza che ho
vissuto è che le differenze culturali i
diversi modi di pensare di abitare il
mondo
non sono un problema sono la nostra
principale opportunità
un opportunità di crescere di migliorare
di costruire un mondo nuovo
se all'inizio ho deciso di condividere
con voi il mio piccolo segreto
adesso visto che ormai c'è confidenza
vorrei condividere con voi la mia più
grande speranza
se avremo il coraggio di abbracciare il
rispetto e il dialogo
allora potremmo dire di essere di un
passo più vicini ad un mondo in cui
nessuno si senta isolato sopportato
se avremo il coraggio di abbracciare il
rispetto e il dialogo
allora potremo dire di essere di un
passo più vicini ad un futuro in cui
nessuno si sentirà tollerato grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]